joining us at the desk are Dominique and
Ashley Sharpton
hi thank you so much for showing up
today just really quickly before we get
into the show I mean your dad is such a
famous figure and for decades I feel
like I've never known a life without the
great Reverend Al Sharpton out there
fighting the good fight he's such a
larger than life figure however what do
we not know about him
okay
whatever you wherever your instincts
just went go I run social media but
basically all day he sends Tick Tock
videos
um from like five in the morning like
literally five in the morning dancing
videos children preaching uh anything
like silly and it's like Dad is dancing
first I thought it was a joke it's like
is this real yeah someone hackers like
he's in our dude he'll text him like did
you see what I sent
to send them to your like phone numbers
and he loves Tick Tock okay good so he's
super cool he loves a little ratchet TV
a little ratchet ratchet TV what is it
like reality yeah he liked Loving Hip
Hop
I watch it all too now of course you
know we everyone knows your dad and uh
but sometimes people
um may not know you including some
former presidents is this true oh God
yeah so the first time I went to the
White House
um president former President George
Bush is President and we went for a
Black History Month event what year
around is this oh I want to say this was
2016. okay so this is W bush Okay yeah W
bush yeah
um and so we go and he starts speaking
and he starts acknowledging some
prominent people in the room and he says
and we're happy to have Reverend Al
Sharpton here and his wife Dominique and
people started like learning on the
audience that's his daughter
so for like the rest of the time the
rest of the day he was like so
apologetic to me like oh really nice
it's like it was adorable but like he
definitely put his foot in his mouth
wow that was my first experience it was
great though okay now your new show is
about growing up having a famous parent
and I love the cast that and you know
the the people that you have on this
show oh yeah you're having people really
interesting people Whoopi Goldberg
Goldberg's daughter is going to be on
granddaughter or granddaughter a
Brandy's daughter is on the show
we spoke with uh the children of uh
Shirley Ralph you know wow who's been
breaking barriers for so long uh so we
spoke with people you know who've been
through stuff like whose parents have
literally sustained Generations you know
being celebrities and being out there in
front and how they've had to actually
Define themselves you know
Ashley are you excited about this
opportunity are you excited about what
you're accomplishing here I'm extremely
excited I first was I was scared but
usually when you're
when you're scared usually up to
something good yeah um so I think it's
an opportunity of a lifetime like
Dominique said we've been behind the
scenes our whole lives we've been
supporting dad from all sides uh and now
it's our time to be like who is
Dominique and Ashley let's show the
world and let me just ask your feelings
about the whole nepo baby thing by the
way I'm a nepo baby I come from a family
I am the paramours and I'm so proud of
it and I am out to change the narrative
because for me I think it's called the
family business well I like that and we
should be carrying the torch and not
undermining anyone for being in the
family business thank goodness that
people are right so it's a little
different with civil rights and social
justice because yeah it's not just like
uh you are appointed to do this you know
because you're in the family I mean you
have to really have the passion
um and you know forget about the skills
and and wanting to really do it the
commitment because it's an emotional
part to it but you've got to really want
to do it thank you for coming and
talking about this wonderful Legacy that
you continue to carry out Dominique and
Ashley the Sharpton sisters heirs
Wednesday at 9pm each on Fox
coming up what's an Italian snack you
may be frying uh never mind we'll be
right back
[Music]